a sudden blow the great wings beating
still above the staggering girl her
thighs caressed by the dark webs her
nape caught in his bill he holds her
helpless breast upon his breast how can
those terrified vague fingers push the
feathered glory from her loosening
thighs and how can body laid in that
white rush but feel the strange heart
beating where it lies a shudder in the
loins engenders there the broken wall
the burning roof and tower and Agamemnon
dead being so caught up so mastered by
the brute blood of the air did she put
on his knowledge with his power before
the indifferent beak could let her drop
lay de and the Swan is a son that
William Butler Yeats wrote and rewrote
many times but finally appeared in this
form in his renowned collection called
the tower published in 1928 when he was
63 the tower was the first book of poems
he released after becoming a Nobel
laureate five years prior Yeats is of
that exceptionally rare breed of artist
who improved in quality as he entered
his late life the poem takes its subject
from Greek mythology the story of Zeus
assuming the form of a swan to seduce
laden wife of the Spartan King Tyndareus
who bore from this union Helen of Troy
whose infidelity ignited the Trojan War
and the beginning of classical history
now before we explore the way Yeats used
this subject to create meaning just take
a quick look at the actual shape of the
poem there's something unsettling about
it the form of the sonnet appears to be
hijacked everywhere it's twisted and
torn apart like dr. Frankenstein Yates
has surgically attached the
Shakespearean sonnet with its first two
quatrains featuring an a B a B rhyme
scheme with the Petrarchan sonnet in the
last six lines and an e FG efg rhyme
scheme including the unnerving slant
rhyme up and drop which robs the final
moment of any auditory closure most
notable of all though is line 11 which
appears to be slashed and split in two
leaving the final three lines just
dangling there like Lleida herself in
the indifferent beak of the Swan in this
way Yeats commits a kind of violence on
the sonnet form not for nothing the poet
is attempting to augment the violent
content of his work sonnets at least she
experienced on its are traditionally
about great love and yet here Yeats uses
the form to describe what could be
considered the exact opposite an act of
violent rape and if you look at
successive versions of Lleida and the
Swan you can see that Yeats
turned up the volume on this violence
for example in one verse
the poem begins a rush a sudden wheel
and hovering still the bird descends her
frail thighs pressed by the webbed toes
and that all-powerful bill has laid her
helpless face upon his breast now the
early version almost assumes ladies
acquiescence to the gods advances in the
later version beginning with the shock
of a sudden blow Zeus's molestation is
intensely emphasized and emphasized - is
Lleida and the readers disorientation
the great wings beating still the
ambiguity of beating still how can wings
be still if they're beating and on the
other hand if he means that they're
still beating
that means terrifyingly that the rape
has already begun while the Swan is
still in the air now in this version the
girl is staggering her thighs caressed a
word that disturbs us by commingling the
erotic with the vicious something that
Yeats does a bunch in this poem caressed
by the dark webs that gives a sense of
just how big the bird is because not
even the toes but the webs between the
toes are what's caressing her and it
should be noted that both the first and
second line end with enjambment pulling
us awkwardly through the verse and it's
not until the last line of that first
that we finally get the subject he as if
everything was happening so fast that
Lleida couldn't find her bearings until
the gruesome act was already underway
the first quatrain of ley de and the
Swan is disturbing in the extreme
setting the scene from laid as horrified
point of view then we have the second
quadrant which is made up of two
rhetorical questions both seem to ask
the same thing
what could lay to do against the awesome
power of a god how could she possibly
resist how can she do anything but feel
the strange heart beating where it lies
these questions can be read in two ways
you can read them rhetorically which is
to say read them is saying obviously she
can't do anything and such is the
tragedy of the poem but I think Yeats
invites us to read them
as well which is to say what can she do
more on that in a moment after the first
two verses comes the Volta a term for
when a sonnet turns and the questions or
events posed in the first lines are
answered in this case after the shutter
referring both to the moment of
ejaculation and latest fear we have the
poet examining the consequences of the
rape and they are really far reach the
broken wall the burning roof and tower
all intimate that the rape of Lleida not
only caused but ensured the eventual
destruction of Troy and the rise of
Greece and Western history a history
that was born out of rape war and murder
and Agamemnon dead here we have Yeats
his own alteration to the mythological
history as the story goes later laid two
eggs one bore Helen and Pollux demigods
and children of Zeus and the other bore
castor and Clytemnestra children of
lados mortal husband Tyndareus who she
laid with the same night by citing the
death of Agamemnon famously killed by
his wife Clytemnestra as among the faded
ramifications of the rape Yeats
demonstrates the full effect of the
trauma and by doing this he reaches into
the history of art as well because the
calls to Troy and agamemnon's death
bring to mind respectively Homer's Iliad
the pinnacle of the epic form and
Aeschylus's play the Oresteia the first
great work of Western drama all this is
done in eleven words without even
mentioning the continued sexual
overtones and then Yeats concludes the
poem with one final question did she put
on his knowledge with his power before
the indifferent beak could let her drop
and to understand this and the poem
itself in its larger context we have to
know a little bit more about Yeats and
his way of thinking from his early life
Yeats had always been drawn to mysticism
to astrology and to the occult in middle
age he developed his own complex met
and cosmic system which he laid out in
extreme detail in a book called
a vision one of the key ideas was that
history was made up into gyres or cycles
of about 2,000 years alternating between
ages of spirituality and ages of
secularism each cycle reached the peak
of its excellence in the exact middle
then decayed slowly until it was finally
replaced by the new one this idea was
explored most potently in his famous
poem the second coming Yeats identified
his own time our time as the end of the
religious cycle of Christianity and
envision the start of a new unknown
cycle of secularism initiated by the
coming of a great beast the last time
such a cycle began is the subject of ley
de and the Swan the rape of ley de by
Zeus signals the start of the Classical
era around 2,000 BC in each case the
divine visits the earth and leaves the
seeds of the history that is to come
this is the key to Yeats his question
did she put on his knowledge with his
power did later glimpse the future she
was creating the cycle
she was inaugurating before the
indifferent God flew away in some way he
suggests the shape of things to come is
contained in its origin but can humans
discern it that's the question now all
this stuff about gyres and cycles and
mystical systems it's pretty out there
clearly it isn't in any way scientific
or even very specific there's a real
debate about whether Yeats believed any
of it probably in some way he did but
what was clearly more important to him
was having a unified system in the first
place because it was from the many
symbols of this unity that Yeats was
able to extract his strongest poetry
having that matrix of sliding meanings
to work with so tightly and intricately
woven meant that pulling one string
evoking
one symbol laying one idea into the form
and metre of a sonnet would make the
rest
of the web light up like a Christmas
tree signifying a complexity that
invites the reader into a number of
simultaneous interpretations by
situating the poem at the fulcrum in
history equal to our own were forced to
look both at what were coming out of and
what we're heading toward a relevant
question for any age particularly
relevant for Yates's own when the trauma
of World War one must have come like a
sudden blow by posing questions of
possible resistance to this brutal act
but showing no resistance on the part
later even possible enjoyment the
readers themselves are called on to
imagine how we resist oppression and the
nature of resistance itself both from a
feminist point of view and a political
one by depicting an encounter with the
divine so savagely we're asked to
examine the price of inspiration and by
posing questions without giving answers
the knowledge and the power of poetry
itself is called into question all these
things are compressed into Yates's
Lleida and the Swan spring load
triggered by an image or a tense or a
pun or a slant rhyme that so much could
be packed into 14 lines and 113 words is
a testament both to Yeats and the
continuing importance of poetry all
that's left is to pull one string and
see what sublime network of meanings
lights up
hey everybody thank you so much for
watching I had so much fun putting this
video together I love this poem I said
in the last video that I'm doing the
nerd writer full time now and and this
is the kind of quality of content that I
can make with this time and this effort
and it's all possible because you guys
have been pledging to the channel on
patreon and I want to continue to ask to
donate a little bit of your money to
this channel because there is so much
more that I want to do and I'm so
excited for the stuff that's coming up
so as little as a dollar you can click
right here on the screen right now
everything helps thank you again so much
if you want to check out another video
you can see my analysis of in the mood
for love which I did a couple weeks ago
great movie I want to expand the series
into a lot of different art forms and
mediums comics even maybe music TV lots
of cool stuff I think there's just a lot
of opportunity for really awesome stuff
and then some stuff that is an
understanding art is coming up too so
thank you again and I will see you next
time